welcome to another video from the ginger
beard of knowledge and we're going to
take a look at the five best moves of
may be the hottest player around at the
moment an erasure firoozeh currently of
Iran or feed a probably moving over to
France remember to like this video and
subscribe to the channel and please do
decide which the following five example
is your favorite move [ __ ] in his first
example the raids are Halle razor he
shows signs of Kasparov flowing through
his blood and he plays in this position
and remember do pause along with some of
these ideas see if you can find the
moves all the examples in this YouTube
video are with the razor with the white
pieces rook takes b7 and this is a
amazing sacrifice and you may remember
that game I showed you all that tactic I
showed you in a previous YouTube video
where Kasparov did a similar move
against shear off to take over the d5
square so that's why this has shades of
Kasparov the point being after Knight
takes e5 the bishop becomes a deadly
piece and after d5 trying to close
things now we have the second
unbelievably beautiful idea
Knight takes d5 point being pawn takes
the knight comes to f5 and even though
White's as a whole
rook down White has this fantastic night
and devastating Bishop which is going to
come into the position this is combined
with factors like an advanced a pawn and
a queen very actively placed white is
doing extremely well here black try to
run away with the King but white now
brought his Bishop into the attack
Bishop c5 plate and a lot of players for
the white pieces here might just bring
the bishop into b7 getting back some
material but not an eraser
he plays b4 continuing to come forwards
and this is a sign of pure aggression if
the bishop is taken Queen g4 attacks g7
and attacks
that bishop so the bishop retreats the
queen comes in anyway only one way to
stop checkmate on g7 and that is by
playing g6 and we have another forwards
move can you see the next blow
aggression aggression aggression is what
needed here pawn to e6 and this allows
the rook to come in at every move is
just fire on the board she rod would
indeed be proud Queen to f6 was played
in the game let's just have a look what
happens if black decides to take this
pawn rook takes e6 is devastating the
tactical idea after something like Queen
takes d5 should be quite easy for you to
see remember pause along if you need to
rook takes g6 and it's devastating you
can work this out yourselves the game
ended very quickly after Queen f6 v 7
rook to e8 and now the last blow another
tactic on tactic Bishop takes f7 check
if Queen takes f7 Knight h6 picks up the
Queen in what we call a fork forking
good time going on there and if King
takes f7 Queen to c4 badly to checkmate
so quite an in-depth tactical sequence
there but let's move on to the second
tactical idea best move that I've picked
from a leader aja ferocious and top
games the second example is beautiful
because it may look like in this
position a white to play that white
can't really escape with his Knight the
knight will just be chased around by
black's rook but with his next move ali
razor comes up with simply astonishing
and very deep concept and this is
against a strong Russian player then
they'll do both
he plays pawn tased e6 now this may not
look astonishing but the foresight
behind this move is what makes it so
special black obviously takes the knight
and now the next move which really glues
in the whole idea rook to e1 and this
rook is coming into the position and
even though black is a piece up or has a
piece for three pawns black cannot move
the rook is tied down to the bishop if
the bishop moves anywhere it will be
chased by the white rook and white
spawns on d6 and a5 just do a job of
containing black's pieces the game
continued King to f8 rook to b7 the rook
finds a good square rook to d8 black
tries to get rid of one of these pawns
but now a6 black does get rid of one of
these pawns but the a7 pawns completely
paralyzes blacks position and bizarrely
black is completely lost here he plays
rook to d8 you have to stop that porn
had rook a six beam played the winning
idea was similar to in the game first
rook to c7 and again it's that paralysis
that we see here what can black play or
should I say not play look at all the
black's pieces and work out very deep
this rook has to stay on the a farm
which doesn't really help the bishop
can't move anyway because if it does
white can play check we see this later
on and Queen the pawn the black King can
only move to these two squares and the
pawns on h7 and g6 can't do anything so
whites winning plan will be to slowly
bring his King into the game and just
win with that King there's nothing black
can do in the game black tried rooks at
the 8th but after rook b7 we still see
this paralysis Bishop c6 rook c7 the
bishop has to retreat black is waiting
for his impending doom and now the King
simply comes there's nothing black can
do in the position and with rook b8
being a serious threats here black tries
to defend an ending which he must
realize is clearly lost as white goes
the exchange up so again a very deep
tactic there we're starting with a very
tough once just to get you into the mood
of this potentially future world
champion on to example number 3 this
next tactic is quite simple in nature
but that is kind of its beauty
it looks in this position like black is
in no danger but after Weis next to
moves is clear black is a serious danger
this is a tactic I'm sure most of you
out there will be able to find pause if
you need to think about how you can
weave a little net around that black
King rook to d8 first check okay pretty
normal but off the king of seven what's
the idea
Bishop c5 and rook to where fates cannot
easily be stopped combined with tactical
eyes at g6 black now has to lose
material so simple tactic yet effective
the game continued rookie seven but now
white wins the exchange he first plays
g6 check and the King has to keep
defending the rook but the following
ending ends up being losing for black
and white wins quite efficiently on to
tactic number four this fourth example
is pure violence white has a lot of
pieces attacking but can you see how he
broke through defense and maybe it's not
the first move that the second move or
even the third move which is really
important in this attack rook takes h7
just destroying defences around the
black King this has to be taken and the
point is after check King g7 white can
play the quiet yet deadly Queen to h4
threatening infiltration on either h7 or
h8 with Czech mate this is a winning
attack the game ended with black trying
to run away with the King but now and
again see if you can finish this game
off in the best way it's still very easy
to mess these positions up so can you
guess the razor's moves Queen to h8
check and here Bishop takes f7 and black
is still a piece up but the point being
route to h7 and whites remaining pieces
are deadly and effective Queen to b6
but now the g7 square is free and after
King to e8
one last deadly and beautiful tactical
idea remember looking out for the checks
can you see it can you
Knight d6 check and this diverts the
black queen away from either the f7
square or the night and the night was
captured if the King tries to move Queen
c7 is checkmate
but it's no better after Queen takes d6
because now white plays Queen f7 check
first and the point being their Queen to
g8 on the next move will be mate because
black cannot block a lovely tactic and
very sharp and crisp bring us to our
last brilliant this last example has a
lovely point to it it's white to play
and white is clearly winning Knight take
c8 would be strong but there's an even
stronger move always look for a better
move than the obvious and can you see it
here and there's a nice little tactic
can you see it can you see it Bishop
takes h6 check and this is a lovely
sweet tactic that forces checkmate
if King takes Knight Queen to h4 and
next move we will deliver checkmate the
black King has nowhere to run and the
main variation goes rook takes h6 and
now we can dive on light it and give it
a lovely little check King to h7 is the
only way to defend the rook
no the knight comes back to f6 another
little check King to g7 draw no thank
you
now what would you play here this is one
of those positions we just do you go for
a queen to put on the board no you go
for a night o night check and next move
Queen takes rook will be checkmate
astonishing tactics there and that
brings us to the end of my five most
amazing move of a D razor firoozeh he
still got him all the time to play some
more amazing moves do you think you'll
be a future world champion he's gonna be
one of the favorites that's for sure a
contender for Magnus's throne
remember to Like and subscribe to this
channel thank you for watching
and do leave below in the comments what
your favorite tactic there was goodbye
for now have Leon look at his videos
[Music]